- [Voiceover] Mohamed
decides to track the number
of leaves on the tree in
his backyard each year.
The first year, there were 500 leaves.
Each year thereafter, the number of leaves
was 40% more than the year before.
Let n be a positive integer,
and let f of n denote
the number of leaves on
the tree in Mohamed's
back yard in the nth year
since he started tracking it.
The expression f of n defines a sequence.
What kind of sequence is f of n?
So, some of you might be able to
think about this in your head.
Each successive year we're growing by 40%,
that's the same thing
as multiplying by 1.4.
Each successive term we're multiplying
or dividing by the same number.
Well, that's going to be geometric.
Let's make that a little
bit more tangible,
just in case.
So, let's make a little table here.
So, table.
So, this is n and this is f of n.
So when n is equal to one,
the first year, n equals
one, there were 500 leaves.
F of n is 500.
Now, when n is equal to two we're going
to grow by 40%, which is the same thing
as multiplying by 1.4.
So 500 times 1.4, let's
do 40% of 500 is 200,
so we're going to grow by 200, so we're
going to go to 700.
Then in year three, we're
going to grow by 40%
of 700, which is 280, so
it's going to grow to 980.
Notice it's definitely not
an arithmetic sequence.
An arithmetic sequence, we would be adding
or subtracting the same amount every time,
but we're not.
Here, from 500 to 700, we grew by 200,
and then from 700 to 980, we grew by 280.
Instead, we're multiplying or dividing by
the same amount each time.
In this case, we're multiplying by 1.4,
by 1.4 each time.
So we are clearly geometric.
Depending on your answer
to the question above,
the recursive definition
of the sequence can have
one of the following two forms.
Well this is the arithmetic form, which
we know isn't the case,
so it's going to be
in the geometric form.
And then they ask us, what are the values
of the parameters A
and B for the sequence?
So we have our base case
here, f of n is going to be
equal to A when n is equal to one.
Well, we know that when n equals one,
we had 500 leaves on the
tree so A, this A over here,
is 500, so A is 500,
and then if we're not in the base case
for any other year,
we are going to have,
let's see, it's going to be
the previous year, the
previous year times what?
It's going to be the
previous year grown by 40%,
to grow by 40%, you're
going to multiply by 1.4
so B is going to be 1.4.
You take the previous
year and you multiply
by 1.4 for any other year,
any year other than n equals one.
So, B is equal to 1.4, and we're done.
Let's do another example.
This is strangely fun.
All right, so this says:
Seo-Yun hosted a party.
She had 50 party favors
to give away, and she
gave away three party
favors to each of her guests
as they arrived at the party.
Let n be a positive integer,
and let g of n denote
the number of party
favors Seo-Yun had before
the nth guest arrived.
All right, actually, before I
even look at these questions,
let me make a table here
because they're saying
before the nth guest.
I want to make sure I'm
understanding this properly.
So this is n,
and then this is going to be g of n,
right over here.
So, when n is equal to one,
when n is equal to one,
g of n is going to be,
or g of one is going to be
the number of party favors
Seo-Yun had before the first guest.
Well, before the first guest,
she had 50 party favors.
She had 50 party favors.
Now, the second guest comes.
Now the number of party
favors she had before
the second guest, well,
she had to give three
to the first guest, so she's now
going to have 47 party favors.
Now, when n is equal to three,
how many party favors did she have
before the third guest?
Well, she would've had
to give party favors
to the first and second
guest, who each got three.
So, she would have 44, and
I think you see the pattern.
For every time n, when n
equals one, g of n is 50,
and every time we increase n by one,
every time we increment
n, we are increasing
g of n by plus three, by
minus three, I should say
because she's giving away
party favors, minus three.
Minus three.
So because the difference
between successive terms
is the same, we know this
is an arithmetic sequence.
This is an arithmetic
sequence and then they say
write an explicit
formula for the sequence.
So let's think about this.
Let's see, g of n is
going to be equal to...
Let's see, we're going to start at 50
then we're going to subtract
three, and let's think,
do we subtract three times n or is it...?
Let's see, for the first guest,
we subtract three zero times.
For the second guest,
we subtract three once.
For the third guest, we
subtract three twice.
So, for the nth guest, we're
going to subtract three
n minus one time.
Notice, for the nth guest,
we subtracted three twice.
The second guest, subtracted three once.
First guest, subtracted three zero times,
so this works out.
For the first guest, we would
subtract three zero times,
and so g of one would be 50.
We can see that this is
consistent for all of these.
So I could write 50 minus
three times n minus one,
and I really recommend
making the table here
just so you make sure
you get the n minus one
or the n right and it all gels.